by reading the emergency evacuation
announcer should we be required to
evacuate the building which you please
leave the building by the news painful
exit there is one fire exit in this room
if you need to evacuate the building to
sell roddick glass door to thee it's a
external fire escape staircase
please hold both cameras in place of
stairs on wet or slippery if anyone is
unable to use the stairs but they will
be substitute members declarations of
interest including afternoon 6 which is
treasury management move into 1819 it's
the video review for this icing this
evening welcome Nami Lucas section 1.1
officer Matt Patni head of finance and
counselor Smith during this year the
review committee received three props on
the council's treasury management
function before the reports are
presented to Council three reports are
the strategy statement the mid-year
review done for me to review this report
is the midterm review and covers the
period first of April 20
18 to 32 September 2018 members will
have had that report circulated to them
just highlight any areas that you wish
to have said and this is the mid-year
canary management review statement and
the purpose of the report is to provide
an update on our returning management
activity for the pier for the first six
months of the financial year
and it's in accordance with the
council's treasury management policy and
treasury management practices so the
mid-year report has been prepared in
compliance if this kind of practice on
treasury management and at paragraph 3
we've provided a brief moment update on
the position yeah the key question is
that the monetary policy can see try to
increase the base rate the Bank of
England will not point five percent in a
point seven five percent in August and
the table at paragraph three point two
shows our treasury management advisory
link custard services view of what
interest rates could do over the next
couple of years so just to sign some
members of the committee that the
treasury management capital strategy
statement them presented to this
committee answer for Council in February
there's no changes to me that strategy
and all that
she's being compliant with that strategy
at section five we show our capital
program and how that financed and we
compare the budgeted estimates and how
the plans to financing those and are
currently estimates which as you can see
I've just slightly lower than our
original budget last points that you
could have been presented to an
executive meeting and no real changes to
our plans to finance the cattle program
so have sex train six we've provided a
summary of our investments at the start
of the financial year investments that
we placed during the first six months of
the year and the balance at 30th of
September the day except for this report
was prepared we've also shown in the
graph of the investments outstanding
from we've chosen to show you from
January to September so the January
position just looks a bit of context in
terms of our overall level of investment
balances that we had to do in the last
financial year and we'll see at the
cutoff point at the 1st of April this
year the balances were slightly lower
than the average and that's just purely
due to cash flow sort of profiling so we
had less cash in the bank at that stage
because we had to pay out a lot of them
a large number of precepts of that at
that particular day so it sort of gave
an artificially low perspective with our
overall balances at that cutoff point
but you can see from the trend that
actually we've now returned to our sort
of 10 million balance and that I think
has been increasing slightly over the
course of this year and we've it's that
sort of increased slightly more going
into the end of this year and that's
paragraph six point four we've just
showed some
my best notes at the snapshot point in
time this report was prepared a purchase
at the edge of September so we can see
that we've got we had three point three
five million pounds in an eye today
account for sometime dare two point four
million with panels banker and five
million pounds in a money market prime
account the forecast investment return
for this year is in line with our budget
which was fifty thousand pounds were
expected to achieve those investment
returns and just to confirm that we've
not reached any of our approved limits
that was a tart with environmental
strategies so that's all I was going to
I asked a question today because of
these Obion scrutiny scrutiny officer to
ask the finance team because I know that
it's not fair to ambush people asking
for a level of detail so I didn't
recognize one particular counter party
that says money market prime so I asked
the overview through the officer to
contact the team and identify the
product the product was was identified
for me it's not being a bank as such but
it fulfilled the triple-a rating I took
a very quick look online only on the
phone so it's a very small screen and
the product appeared to have a
description of share in it and another
link showed me that payments were made
in terms of dividends and I asked for an
explanation of that I didn't receive it
what I'd asked for this evening and the
straighten of the second health there's
an in February we set a policy and
strategy and as such I hope you're able
to tell me that that particular
counterparty completely fulfills the
part of the policy that stick ours is
going to read out right
the organization was at money market
funds triple-a long-term credit rating
maximum duration was on call and can be
withdrawn immediately and the maximum
investment
okay it just Skyfire that's not an
organization per say it is a fund that
we money into but just to confirm that
is complied with our strategy which
that's out that we can invest in money
market funds up to five million pounds
money market funds so they're not
there's a number of different funds that
it has potentially invest in and our
strategy sets out the parameters with
which we can do that but it's not a
particular organization as in example
Lloyd's or sometimes areas and
organization its own right it's a fund
which then spreads the risk by investing
in a number of different institutions
and manages the risk in that way so we
are guaranteed the return of our capital
and the rate of return that we don't get
from that in is a variable rate but
essentially it's still meets our
criteria of a triple-a triple-a rated
investment
okay following the report wit only
because I know this it says money market
prime just a small thing is is prime but
the name of a bundle is that what's the
difference between I mean just have
money market funds so this is money
market prime what's the difference so I
think there's two classifications of
money market funds are specified in our
treasury management strategy so I've
actually they called standard enhanced I
don't know if Matt wants to elaborate on
the point yes I cannot success so we we
have access to we currently have set up
three money market accounts due to the
nature of the return on those accounts
were only actively using one of them
which is this one here called money
market prime the actual money market
fund is with an organisation called
federated investors the fund itself is a
prime rate classification 3 fund it
forms specifically within our policy a
strategy that was presented to this
committee back in January February time
it is solely cash its council Masons
question was regarding shares and
potential dividends I can confirm it is
a cash investment fund we've placed 5
million pounds in that cash fund as it
stands I have a look today that fund has
a total balance of 3.8 billion pounds of
which our five million is part of that
so your point 1 3 percent of the phone
these our balance and what they do they
pull those investments from all over all
different organizations who buy into
that fund and they diversify across
banks and girls societies to get you a
rate of return
it's confirm it's not shares per se the
terminology is we have a share of that
fun but it's not buying shares it's it's
the better word to use will be a unit
Matthew is there an agreed return I mean
on some of these that you know it's 0.1%
point seven point five percent with this
operation is is it a variable return and
no designated bottom line or a
designated bottom line it could be above
there say you guarantee to get your
investment back as a minimum as a righty
yeah if for example today I put 500,000
say in that fund it will give me the
right as at that point of doing the deal
right in that deal and that would be the
right we used to work out a rough
estimate of interest earn on that deal
but that fund would obviously fluctuate
here but the nature of its it's instant
access so we can get the money out
straight away there's no time period of
delay it's instant access fund I have I
would say though that the money market
funds are the reason we use it is
because it's giving us on average
roughly 10 basis points better than
putting the instant access anywhere else
so that's why authorities use money
market funds more than they would say
leaving the current account or or have
an instant access account directly with
a bank I think it's important to
exercise the key things is that it has
laxatives it's a liquid investment so we
can draw funds at any time and the main
criteria of off the pond is to maintain
the safety of the principal so it is a
very safe safe investments
it's it's rated very highly on credit
rates at school so it's in line with our
low risk strategy and as such it was
approved as part of the strategy is
amazing I think you're just a quick
question this is a matter of curiosity
you groups and the major investments
spread across three large accounts
there's this I've missed it I can't see
any indication of interest rate I know
you've said that that one is variable
but there should be some indication of
variances that you'd anticipate a 90 day
account I would expect to have a fixed
rate of interest anyway perhaps you
could just clarify this for me yes so
the current the 90 day sons and their
account he's hanging information he has
paid 1% this svenska handles banking is
paying point six five percent and as I
say the money market is variable but it
tends to pay around I mean this morning
we could have got point seven three
percent but it variates around that few
best points either side but generally
between nine and ten most points above
the other two what Bob spends going away
for short yeah okay thank you
cancel standing Thank You chairman two
things really who comprise the the
interest rate that you've got for up to
15 years and also
who is working on a monthly basis on the
interest rates to this money market
thing or are we doing weekly or what
what is the strategy they're putting the
first question so the 50-year pwl B
right is the right that the probably
work line sport is currently operating
at MIT now Dennis link assets view of
how that rate is likely to change in
line with their projected changes to my
base rates latter projections going
forward but it the the 50 right there
wasn't it
32 the 50 years just who compose that
that schedule I'm so sorry I'm not maybe
I knew this I'm sorry Amish Ben do you
want to say clarify in the report six
more to from place right in carbon right
the way through to 15 years saying 0.2
and it's composed from from yeah yeah
sure that's what I'm trying to get any
said do you think that that's what
we agree with ya we with the reason we
employ a professional specialist advice
is to take it for that it's obviously it
will obviously we we are in conversation
with them and if we don't understand or
agree with anything we have a
conversation with them after all they've
arrived at that but generally we tend to
go with our advice about the how do you
operate your monthly check on the money
market so we monitoring our investments
on a daily basis on a daily basis okay
thank you okay thank you very much
councillor mr. Mason thank you I just
want to I suppose put a couple of things
to you and put them on the record
one thing was interesting you described
the total in the fund if I don't use the
right terminology stop me over 3.8
billion and I certainly saw that this
morning you indicated that that was
placed across various banks and building
societies using the words you use but of
course what we don't know and this is an
observation is whether those particular
counterparties fulfill our own credit
policy I'm just going to say that the
second part is you mentioned a guarantee
as far as I understand it there is no
guarantee at all to a local authority or
a corporate for monies placed with any
counterparty so although he referred to
being triple-a there's no guarantee
triple-a you know in reality can go bust
just like anybody else that West Bank
was triple-a it isn't triple-a now not
only because it's owned by RBS but it's
much lower than triple-a and I would
just say those are observations I need
to make them I need to put them on the
record
thank you would you
yeah it's an observation I think in
terms of the second point it's right to
say that no investment is completely
risk-free so the nature of investments
is though there is always a slight mess
but in terms of their lead sort of range
of risks we can take is ultimately out
there absolute ended their lowest
spectrum and treasury management advises
when you look back at the history of
those funds they write none there's
naught point naught naught naught 4
percent risk and that's the lowest risk
category after anything return on it
it's occurred to me that you know quite
a lot about this fund we share these
good news can you tell me whether we've
ever invested in this before and when
did we we have been using the Federated
prime rate fund for a number of years I
can't off top my head remember when we
opened it we've had it at least five
years but I can give you the exact date
that circulated
just develop if I may so it's never
appeared in any report to review
committee as a counterparty because it
hasn't as far as I remember it would
have always been on average cancer party
but it wasn't necessarily in a report so
is that big let me ask my question
things
so therefore we'll have to assume that
we haven't invested in this counterparty
at any particular point of time on a
report other one because this is as at
the 30th of September so it just so
happens 30th of September we had news
that counterparty we have used it before
that it doesn't appear to me at least to
appeared in a year in poor as it counts
I can't categorically say without
obviously checking through the archives
of our reports but if if at any point in
the year at the start of the year sorry
at the end of the year when we do our
report or an immediate report we had it
invested it would have been it would
have been reported in US and the laser
lights printed here but we can we can
check that and come back see on 29th
November 2016 that the review committee
money-market prime is detailed in 29th
of November 2016 so it has appeared
before I did say chairman very carefully
as far as I was aware
I'm Katherine Pierce did you know no you
found that oh thank you I'm
self-questioning
5.3 it refers to forums there's a census
there that says if the council does
decide for it externally in future and
policy will need to be agreed and
implemented would it not be prudent is
it possible to have a policy agreed and
implemented prior to borrowing so that
if you did need to borrow it would
already be done or can it only be done
is it so specific to a particular boring
meaning that it would have you have to
be done then I mean I'm assuming other
people have things in place already have
because yes I mean there is board
guidelines for exiting MLP policy it
would operate within we do have a so
important statement in our strategy that
sets out sort of that we would comply
with the relevant legislation that the
MRP policy does relate to the type of so
in the nature of the investment that you
want to vote for in the profiling and
that sort of thing so I think it would
need to be guided by our actual plans
for our capital investment and borrowing
strategy so although you can have more
principles we wouldn't necessarily want
to commit to a sort of a detailed there
are people to see until we broke clear
idea of what it had some intense bro I
mean who know that we don't yeah that's
one of these I'm not having a policy in
place that if ever we needed to put
although the family didn't have one
agreed and implemented could actually I
think that we haven't set out a
requirement for buying the 1819 strategy
so if we ever did intense bar I think it
would be brought before the committee
and we would make the relevant
amendments
bringing us through that before that for
such time as we would be looking
surprised I think members of the
committee would have good sight orb
anyone see before it isn't thank you
thank you I'm just for clarity this has
been raised by the old something went to
the Audit Committee to be aware of it
that the need to be writing is correct
as you know me is coming the VRP has
been raised by the auditors and as being
at least the last couple of all due
committees that I've been to is being
wrapped within the reports themselves if
not raised at the committee themselves
about the mo face I think he's covered
as well on that committee Thank You
chairman man it's on the back of your
question in relation to having a policy
in place pranced boring if there isn't a
specifically detailed policy in advance
of borrowing rekon would that actually
slow the process of getting approval for
borrowing any money and you know you're
going to limit the council's ability
timescales and things like that I'm not
anticipating it would have any adverse
impacts on timelines I think the nature
of any strategic projects that we
undertake with me we'd have good sort of
line of sight over the sort of six
months at least to a year and Paul we
were looking to actually take out any
boring so that should give us adequate
time to make sure we've got the
appropriate and policies in place if we
need to amend them so I wouldn't
anticipate equals and any holdups in the
report there is a reference that was
meant to be nice in the
generally just did we see increasing
weights
I'll stop note from press at the time
although there was an increase in love
thanks necessarily past that yeah we did
see an increase in our
[Music]
moving on which is the addition of the
officer assistance in the first
paragraph services one support some
patient these 21 working days before the
meeting to allow for preparation time
with up to three notices per meeting
depending on officer resource required
don't I'm assuming that by that that
means three notices per meeting up for
counsel for example but what would
happen if those three notices what those
three motions were requiring the
assistance of one officer jambo stock
came up with this and sadly is not here
Paul will definitely put me right if I
speak incorrectly but John took took
this away because we kept on asking him
and saying has the council drop capacity
to provide this additional
assistance and what would you recommend
as being the DMV appropriate parameters
to put around it and he couldn't ask
answer a straightaway but he very
digitally went away
and when we came to the point of
drafting it was John who having spent
obviously not only his own time with his
team and others came back and said we
can we can manage three four council
that may require assistance and that is
within capacity to do and he also came
up with the 21 working days because we
again felt that it was a matter of food
prudent planning
so we've relied on John Bosco in his
role as system directed democratic
services to the A's with other offices
and to come back to us with a
recommendation that recommendation we
found acceptable so it formed part of
this report Millman's on that task group
isn't he he's not on this committee no
it's a shame he's not here because he
played a very big part in in actually
putting this together and I think I'm
quite sad actually because there was at
least one time when I said I don't
understand that and he was very good he
said oh that's actually in the voice of
the councillor Paul so I say oh is it
I've lost sight of that
so we've got to think so for his input
in this money I don't really have that
much been issue with that point house
the only thing I was thinking was doing
all those three motions per meeting
knocking is it's quite reasonable I just
wondered
if the demands 5:3 emotion or on one
officer be considered too much I think
mr. chairman with Nomi has seemed that
the mr. bill stop considered that and
consider it reasonable Hey
he was exceptionally helpful and
actually he almost wrote it because
though we had a consensus in the meeting
we weren't sure how to word it and he
went away he worded it and then if the
wording was circulated in a great viral
members so we can't answer that question
because the it's an officer
recommendation I would certainly think
that our officer especially in the ID
Democratic services should have a great
understanding of what the council can
thank you Jim don't you have a problem
with I think is quite good idea I just
rotated to say without to three motions
and depending on office types that's
quite these are quite loosely worded the
many who say so give me that gives the
ability to say we can only vote on for
two motions or one motion nothing that's
pretty reasonable go I think the young
issues not really a big issue it's just
a common probably and maybe something we
should look at to see if it works or we
don't exactly have three motions every
needs because I really like doing so I'm
not sure how it working it it says if
members consider considering the special
motion they started off saying that
members who want a portfolio hold up or
on the executive in other words it
doesn't restrict it within this wording
as I understand it two members who
aren't part of the executive and I
suppose there's also the possibility
that one one group of one party may
decide to use all three votes remove
three motions or usual officer time and
deny the ability of another group or
other members
to do the same so he's just I don't
think that would particularly happen but
I think of something maybe we should
keep an eye on just on big beds maybe
look at it later if it if that does
happen we did we didn't say this is a
job named Paul and others will bear this
out we did say that I'm sure and this
this is truly meant that there would be
a great deal of cooperation between
others in the event that there was a
particular problem and I feel that we're
all adults and we're all extremely
sensible and you know we're in
particular officers your to your point
were to have three pretty hefty items
but there would be there would be some
sense in parties in sorting things out
which of course the managing director
has jurisdiction to do anyway because
let's face it he's got complete control
over all of the resources and start or
stop Thank You councillor Stanley I was
just going to say that that's the whole
point of this review of the force of the
council is to give everybody an equal
opportunity and as much time to to
evaluate with these with these notices
and the fact that John did so and say
that I believe I'm right in saying that
he's only had maybe two in the past year
so with this in mind and this is what we
was talking about in consultation with
him was that he this is what he's come
up on the basis that that's all he ever
had previously
thank you I think at the time when we
were discussing this we were concerned
about the number of working days that we
should allow officers to investigate and
transformation said I think we're all in
agreement with what John Bosco has come
up with with at least 21 days notice
[Applause]
there are two recommendations for the
next year reveal and suggest any areas
that the committee may like to examine
in terms of possible policy changes that
could improve and the second is further
proposed by the Working Party that this
piece even recommends to council changes
of motion in the Constitution be adopted
thank you just disappointing somebody
simply commenting on how constructive
castamere deals in a court was and I
wasn't aware at that time that he was
not on the committee the other members
obviously the working group on this
committee perhaps we ought to thank him
for his for money for his assistance to
this committee is working as a smelling
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
the first one is the only one through
seven air quality project outline final
business case and I remember in November
stating that he was kind of producer
report in December like today it's gonna
be looking like that will not be part of
the process as this progresses and it's
likely that that item will be removed
from the key decision document next
month because we are in compliance on
our bits of the one to seven I'm
assuming if that is okay yes you will
get a formal notice of distres Nobles
and Martin's promise that he will give
members of that day to the members
bulletins about the a one through seven
air quality project well we get breath
after so to show that we are I can
asking for a job infrared yes because if
it's only recent that we're doing it
then there that we know that we're gonna
do it in the future I want it not see
them I see that one yeah they can only
answer that yet but that's the water
yeah if you could shun the weird title
be provided blowing it away
and their long I don't know I don't know
end day this is everything I was going
to ask you mr. but the one the one two
seven that we can be nine major highway
promote way from the air quality will
their air quality project come back into
play then possibly accommodate Martine
but marched in my own I'm sure Martin is
like another meeting with you Chris
already oh no quite ever done thank you
we'll take it offline just remember to
wait to lose been moving on to the
number 1218 advice services contract one
that's being decided by the exec
tomorrow night and you should have all
seen the report by now on that and
finally we have one live one fourteen
nineteen and that's gonna be the
register policy subcommittee counselor
I haven't been advised of anything yet
but I would be very hopeful they will
come to us I'm sure the chairman of that
can made my weight asking that's right
well we still got mister good dentist I
could ask at me I have as far as I'm
aware but you know as much as I do but
you could request the communist one
question do we have any idea how
comprehensive the brownfield prejudice
but it includes land owned by the
Ministry of Defense or Network Rail
organizations chairman what I can tell
you is we've already got one we can look
at it yeah so you know already what's in
it
currently I would honestly say if you
think you know about the brownfield
sites have them been put in there but
you think Marcus or Sean will be very
pleased to hear from you yeah or Natalie
made even better
to be quite frank yeah we do know the
scope with you already
yeah
I just point out 8 the January you'll
have the operation in the development
committee and enforcement of dog family
for now and cotton there are are there
any issues when you were speaking about
office ism there's also the previous
item I do know that Marcus is now
leading planning as well as leaning
environment so I just wonder have we
asked him have you asked him is he ok
with three both that month he was
showing me the report for the planning
one this morning we were chatting about
it he is working on both of them he's
had a month or more to get his head
around that one and I've been fashioning
most days on it so yes I was just gonna
say that the managing director is
obviously chosen very well so
Memphis
[Applause]